with businesses moving online and
shifting to cloud storage
currently the demand for cyber security
is at its peak with that comes a high
demand for cyber security experts who
can safeguard digital data
on that note hey guys welcome to yet
another exciting video by simply learn
in this video we bring you the top five
cyber security skills
but before we begin if you are new here
and haven't subscribed already
make sure to hit the subscribe button
and the bell icon for interesting tech
videos every day
so let's get started according to cyber
crime magazine by cyber security
ventures
globally there would be nearly 3.5
million unfilled cybersecurity jobs by
2021
and the number of internet users will
hit a whopping 6 billion by 2022.
these numbers speak volumes and this
shows the growing demand for cyber
security professionals across the globe
now that you know the high demand for
cyber security professionals
let us help you start your cyber
security career by bagging the right
skill set
many of you out there might be waiting
to become a cyber security professional
but are unsure of how to go about it and
what skills you would need to get a
cyber security job
not to worry we are here to help you
with that after extensive research we
have come up with the top five skills
that will help you get into the field of
cyber security
let's have a look at these skills
individually
first we have networking and system
administration
the number one skill you need to have to
enter the field of cyber security is
computer networking
networking is the backbone of the
internet it is imperative that you have
an in-depth understanding of networking
to start a career in cyber security
a network is a group of interconnected
devices and networking is the art of
understanding how data is sent
transmitted and received amongst these
devices
you need to know various routing
protocols the tcp
and osi models govern networking the osi
model is comparatively newer
basically in these models all the
protocols are grouped into layers and
work together to help you receive data
on your device
sent from a server learning networking
will help you understand the technical
aspects of data transmission which will
help you secure your data
you can take up networking
certifications like security plus and
cisco ccna to gain
a strong networking foundation another
skill that will be beneficial for you is
to master system administration
if you think about it all of us are cis
admins at some level
system administration is all about
configuring and maintaining computers
you must be curious to know every aspect
of your computer features
and settings and play around a bit carry
out a trial and error method and give
yourself small tasks like recovering
deleted files or monitoring old viruses
on a vm
explore new techniques put them into use
and expand your knowledge
let us now move on to our second skill
knowledge of operating systems
and virtual machines to become a cyber
security professional you need to have a
strong knowledge of operating
environments such as windows linux and
mac os
cyber security professionals largely use
linux and it comes with several tools
to learn operating systems go ahead and
set up and use virtual machines that is
vms
and play around with them this will help
you gain hands-on experience
as a cyber security expert you should be
comfortable working on any os
vms allow you to train and research in
an isolated environment and help you
maximize your skills
the next point to remember is to know
kali linux
it is the most widely known linux
distribution for ethical hacking and
penetration testing
it comes with several hundred tools
related to penetration testing malware
analysis security research
computer forensics and so on kali
contains
several projects and you can learn a lot
another good thing about kali is that it
is free to use
so what are you waiting for download and
start right away
remember that linux is the backbone of
cyber security and a commonly asked
topic for cyber security interviews
especially for pen testing roles
moving on to our third skill our third
skill is network security control
it is another basic skill that every
cyber security professional should have
network security control refers to the
different measures which are employed to
enhance the security of a network
it is simple you can only safeguard your
network if you know how it works
how routers firewalls and other devices
work
a firewall is a hardware or software
that blocks incoming or outgoing traffic
from the internet to your computer
firewalls are required to secure a
network as a cybersecurity expert you
must be able to leverage a firewall to
filter and prevent
unauthorized traffic onto the network in
addition to that as a cyber security
expert you must know about intrusion
detection systems
intrusion prevention systems virtual
private networks and remote access
an intrusion detection system ids is
designed to detect unauthorized access
to a system
it is used together with a firewall and
a router
you should be able to operate the ids
and recognize any security policy
violations and malicious traffic on the
network
as many of you may have used a vpn is a
connection between a vpn server
and a vpn client it is a secure tunnel
across the internet
moving on next up we have an interesting
skill any idea what that is
if yes pause and leave a comment as to
what you think the next skill will be
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description
to know more
and before we jump into this skill if
you find this video interesting make
sure to give it a thumbs up
fourth skill on our list is coding so
you might be wondering if coding is
really required to become a cyber
security professional
well it is true that not all cyber
security professionals have or need
coding skills
however having zero coding knowledge may
limit your opportunities in the future
knowing a couple of programming
languages will help you identify the
plan behind an attack and defend against
deadly hacking techniques
so as seen on your screens these are the
best programming languages to learn to
make your cybersecurity career
worthwhile
we have c and c plus plus the c
programming language is the backbone of
most operating systems
c and c plus plus are low level
programming languages that you need to
know as a cyber security professional
on the other hand python is a high level
programming language that is becoming
popular among cyber security experts
today
knowing python will give you an upper
hand in your career
it will help you identify and fix
vulnerabilities
javascript is another high-level
programming language that adds
interactivity to web pages a good
advantage of knowing javascript is that
you can prevent cross-site scripting
attacks from occurring
as in these attacks the attacker
implants malicious code in a web
application
speaking of php because most of the
websites are created using php
learning it will help you defend against
intruders
similarly html is another language cyber
security professionals should understand
as most websites use it
and it is one of the easiest languages
to learn
another programming language that you
can use is golang
it is great for cryptography you can
solve various cybersecurity problems
with it
then we have sql that is structured
query language
attackers use this language to damage
the stored data
one such example is the sql injection
attack hence having a good understanding
of sql will be highly beneficial
another point we'd like to highlight is
to have knowledge of assembly language
this will help you become a cyber
security engineer assembly will help you
understand how malware functions and
thereby help you defend against it
in the cyber security domain you can't
just lock into a single language
and hence it is advised that you're
acquainted with a couple of them
you can also do a crash course for these
languages and learn them
hence determine the best programming
language for your cyber security role
and get familiar with the basics moving
on our fifth skill on the list is cloud
security
there is a growing demand for cyber
security professionals with cloud
security skills in the coming years
companies are on the lookout for
professionals with security skills
applicable to public
and hybrid cloud platforms such as
amazon web services and azure
more organizations look to cloud
infrastructure to store data and run
applications
this includes the implementation of
policies and technologies that protect
cloud-based systems and devices
just like application development
security cloud security also involves
building secure systems from the start
companies want professionals who can
manage the cloud security tools to
identify and prevent any cloud breaches
people with experience and knowledge in
managing big platforms such as microsoft
azure aws
and the gcp are in high demand now that
we have seen the top five cybersecurity
skills
let us go through a set of additional
skills that can help you get into the
cyber security field
remember that to become a successful
cyber security expert you must possess a
rich
and diverse skill set so in a list of
additional skills first we have risk
analysis
identifying risks even before their
arrival is a great skill
cybersecurity professionals are required
to identify manage and mitigate risks
risk management and mitigation is a
skill set that is going to be highly in
demand in the coming years
next we have information security
companies require skilled professionals
who can protect their electronic data
from unauthorized taxes
here in demand skills are authentication
authorization malware analysis and data
recovery
next on our list is security incident
handling and response
as a cyber security expert you must be
prepared to handle any forthcoming
threat of violating an organization
security policy
by following an updated incident
response plan your team can proactively
protect your data and minimize the
damages
in security incident management you are
required to identify manage record and
analyze security threats in real time
a security incident can be an active
threat or a successful compromise of
data or an attempted intrusion
it can also be incidents like ddos
attacks phishing apts ransomware and
many more
another important pointer is that as a
security practitioner you must also
manage and analyze the security
information and event management
siem tools and services
on we have security audit security
auditing is an internal check that is
carried out to find flaws in the
organization's information system
you must be able to conduct a review of
the organization's adherence to
regulatory guidelines
security audit and compliance knowledge
are very crucial as
any missed area of regulatory compliance
could lead to hefty penalties
soon organizations will need people who
are more familiar with the various data
privacy regulations
if you are good at paperwork you can
capitalize on this skill
companies will need people who can
understand what paperwork to file and
which security protocols to use to
comply with the regulations
finally we have loss and regulations and
often overlooked cyber security
aspect there are several cyber security
laws and regulations
and if you break these laws
intentionally or not it doesn't matter
as you will still be charged
these laws define how you can use the
internet and it also defines how people
can be protected from becoming the
victims of cyber crimes
knowing these laws and regulations and
following the best practice will make
you ethical at your job
and this will in turn be good for your
organization
so those were our list of additional
skills apart from these make sure you
stay updated with new hacks and learn
new tools as cyber security is ever
evolving
another important skill apart from these
technical skills is your soft skills
having a set of good soft skills will
help you bag your dream job
we have a video on the top 5 soft skills
that will help you grow in your career
do watch that and incorporate those
skills as well
so with that we come to the end of this
video on the top 5 cyber security skills
do you agree with our list
think we missed anything important do
let us know in the comment section below
thank you so much for being here and do
watch out for more videos from us
until then keep learning and stay tuned
to simply learn
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here